porque puede permanecer en el cargo un
líder que prácticamente fue obligado a
renunciar como es el caso de boris
johnson que se va a quedar hasta octubre
igual teniendo en cuenta que muchas
personas dentro de su mismo partido
conservador pues no quieren que llegue
hasta octubre que está pasando y qué
puede pasar digamos en este escenario
que estamos planteando
primero buenos días muchas gracias por
la invitación
efectivamente estamos ante un proceso
cuya dinámica habrá que ver cómo avanza
fundamentalmente estamos hablando de un
proceso que inicialmente va a ser
interno del partido conservador en tanto
a la renuncia no solo al cargo de primer
ministro sino primero y principal al
cargo del líder del partido
por ende ahí se lo que se inicia son es
el proceso interno justamente para
renovar ese liderazgo que puede como
bien dice usted durar un par de meses
pero hay oposición a que esto sea así ya
lo decía recién la corresponsal hay
opiniones de que esto tiene que resolver
rápidamente sea de manera interna
cambiando el liderazgo hacia el
viceprimerministro o acelerando los
tiempos para la renovación del liderazgo
del partido conservador o también la
otra alternativa que hoy también se está
discutiendo es la que están proponiendo
pongámosle desde la oposición es si el
partido laborista de impulsar una moción
es ashura que acelere una elección
anticipada que obviamente en el contexto
actual podría favorecer al partido
laborista eso le quería decir
precisamente porque ante todo este
escándalo político y esta debilidad que
está mostrando por así decirlo ahora
frente a todo un país y frentes
opositores del partido laborista
hablamos del partido conservador porque
entonces el próximo primer ministro
tiene que salir de este bloque digamos
que tendría que pasar realmente para que
los laboristas se pudieran salir a unas
votaciones generales para ver si los
británicos votarían a por el partido
laborista para que ellos los representen
en el gobierno
recordemos que estamos hablando un
parlamentarismo primero entonces el
proceso de elección es diferente al que
tenemos nosotros en un presidencialismo
y en este sistema entonces el sistema
británico concretamente el primer
ministro es el jefe del partido
mayoritario hoy el partido mayoritario
es el partido conservador y por tanto el
real ministro va a venir de ese partido
siempre y cuando no haya una renovación
en lo que es la cámara de los comunes
para que haya una renovación en las
cámaras comunes y cambian las mayorías
tiene que darse una elección general
anticipada
y proponer esa esa esa elección implica
disolver la cámara actual y la forma que
hoy se piensa para hacer eso si es que
el gobierno no llama a esa elección
e impulsar una salida a partir de la
emoción y que eso sí presiones para que
esa elección general pueda llevarse
adelante entre entonces para responder
rápido así para que el partido laborista
se transforme en gobierno tiene que
cambiar la relación de fuerzas en la
cámara los comunes bueno y esa elección
a lo mejor no puede estar muy distante
porque recordemos que precisamente el
día de ayer el propio boris johnson dijo
que una elección general pues le caería
muy mal al país en este momento pero
igual pues todo puede pasar hernán
última pregunta ya tenemos un minuto
pero quien podría ser obviamente la
pregunta del millón la que todo el mundo
quisiera saber quién podría hacer este
nuevo sucesor de johnson bueno hay que
ver como para hacerlo rápido como es la
dinámica que lo que también está
ocurriendo como bien dice usted si es el
partido laborista hoy es el jefe de la
oposición starmer si es si es dentro del
partido conservador la elección a hoy
hay un listado bastante amplio que
involucra a diferentes alternativas
entre los cuales varios funcionarios
recientes del partido que han sido los
que han
esta bomba de salida masiva como xavi o
o también personas como
lo que es la
secretaria defensa del partido
conservador